welcome back to las vegas now with the
holiday weekend approaching eric
palacios and associates the sponsors of
this next segment want to remind you to
drive responsibly rocky checked in with
our las vegas now expert to learn more
welcome back eric
hi rocky good to be here good to see you
and now labor day is coming up so we've
got to talk holiday driving what do
drivers need to be aware of out there
well be extra cautious a lot of times
drivers are out having a good time
going to family gatherings sometimes
restaurants and bars so you always want
to be extra careful uh there might be
somebody out there driving under the
influence also if you've had a few let
somebody else do the driving be safe and
get home to your loved ones always
something to think about anywhere you
are but especially in las vegas so what
are the penalties of a dui
in case somebody out there forgot
they're pretty harsh uh they involved uh
time in jail
stiff fines also you have to go to a
victim impact panel where you get to
hear people who've lost a loved one due
to a dui tell their stories it's very uh
sad very difficult to
sit through
also you have to go to dui school you
lose your license for a period of time
so there's many many penalties on top of
that you usually hire an attorney to
help defend you against the charges so
you're looking at ten thousand fifteen
thousand uh in expenses by the time you
add everything up absolutely you don't
want your holiday fun to turn out so
serious and so tragic um do you see more
arrests happening during the holidays
generally yes because the police are
more active
looking for people that are driving
under the influence we see uh
checkpoints a lot of times and with the
increase in police activity you also see
increase in arrests and charges of dui
okay that makes sense and because we are
in vegas lake mead is somewhere that
people go celebrate the holidays at so
is this something that we need to be
aware of while we're boating or hanging
out at the lake
great question and yes lake mead is a
great place to be uh for this long
weekend a lot of boaters a lot of people
out there but we also have to keep in
mind that just like you can get a dui
for driving a car the same applies for
driving a boat uh you can't just uh
drink and go drive your boat you have to
be careful the same laws apply and since
lake mead is in a national park the
charges are federal uh so a little bit
more stiff on the charges and a little
bit more uh difficult to deal with as
well okay that is a very important
reminder the streets and the water
they're both just as dangerous so thank
you so much eric for your tips that is
excellent advice everybody drive safely
this weekend yes everyone be safe and
we'll see you next week all right see
eric
thank you to eric palacios and
associates for sponsoring this segment
for more information give them a call at
702 444
that is too many numbers 444-7777
you can also visit their website at
ericpalacioslaw.com
we'll be right back